hey guys it's John from gex spot and I
wanted to put together another quick
video this time on aggregate decks we're
not going to get too much
into uh reading it just this is mainly
just for people to understand what it is
um in case uh you don't want to read the
docs or the docks are confusing or
whatever although I should mention that
all this information is in the docs
under the resources tab um in order to
understand aggregate decks we actually
kind of want to start with uh Dex
orderflow so right now I'm I clicked on
Dex orderflow on our orderflow Tab and I
have uh These Bars going up and down and
I'm on latest 1122 which is today Friday
November the 22nd um
so um each of these bars represents uh a
transaction or a set of transactions
that came through and were classified as
either bought or sold um and we're
measuring the Delta exposure of those
transactions uh the Delta of an option
is its share equivalent so if I were to
buy a 50 Delta spy call for instance um
that option is going to behave more or
less like 50 shares of spy um
so if you think about converting that
into the amount of money that you would
need I'm not sure exactly what Spy is
trading right now but let's say spy's
trading at around um 500 bucks for the
purposes of this example and you bought
a 50 Delta spy call um it's like having
50 shares of spy um which is like
putting
$25,000 into the Spy ETF right and so
we're essentially measuring um how much
money you would need to put into the
underlying uh in order to uh replicate
that option so um actually we should
just hop over to spy so I
can show you that um so like let's say
we're looking at this bar here that came
in at 945 it says de order flow 29.1 148
um that's saying that you would need to
put um the units of this are in uh
Millions so it's essentially uh $29
Million worth of um Capital um so that's
what I would call the notional exposure
of that of that transaction this is not
super necessary to know when you're
using this to to trade or make decisions
um but it is just useful to understand
that
um when we're when we're looking at
aggregate decks when we're looking at
Dex order flow that's basically what
we're measuring like how much money did
they basically put in or take out of the
market so here we're seeing that they
you know put a lot in that's why it's
positive and then here they took a lot
out so why it's negative um and we can
see for instance right like in this case
with spy it's pretty clear you know we
we jerked up to the top of the range and
then somebody just slammed it right they
basically said nope that's it you're
done um and this was basically the
biggest uh transaction that we saw so
far that day um I think yeah which we
can well I guess there's a difference uh
from because we had a big transaction at
the open but um that's also what this
orderflow filter is useful for just a
quick note um the way that the orderflow
Filter Works currently is that it'll
take the largest transaction and then uh
slice that up into percentages and then
whatever presented you select on the
order flow filter shows all transactions
that are that percent of the largest
transaction so far that day it is um
something that we're thinking about
changing a little bit just because uh
sometimes it doesn't let you get
granular enough but uh when we do change
it that will be updated in the docs if
you want to understand aggregate decks
all you have to do is imagine that as
all these transactions are happening
over the course of the day um we're
adding all of them up that's why it's
called aggregate um so basically have
people been buying more shares by way of
options or have they been selling more
shares by way of options um and so let's
actually try to hop over to Agate decks
for spy to take a look at that um and so
for um for net aggregate decks which is
what I was just talking about adding
everything up you want to focus on this
uh teal line
here and all this is telling us is that
over the course of the day uh people
have been using spy options to get short
the market um now do we know what else
they're doing are they maybe shorting
the market with options but buying
shares at the same time yeah possibly um
that will that is sort of a different
issue that maybe I'll get into another
video which is you know how to actually
read this um while understanding like
whenever you're looking at any
particular ticker you you have to have a
a little bit of experience having seen
it before understanding how participants
trade it um because um it doesn't just
make sense to take a symbol like a
signal like this and and and trade it
blindly while it is the case that with
spy often times things trade a little
bit more directionally um because people
are using the options so much um so it's
fair to say in this case that I I I
would say that like spy Traders are
generally short to neutral the market
right this isn't like a crazy reading on
aggregate decks which is also something
that you'll get from experience but um
anyway the point is just that oh and I
can actually show this to you guys by
doing this um because you can kind of
combine the two oh and if you want um to
be able to scale without things going
crazy just disable the the autometric
scaling and then you can do this um and
it'll
stick anyway we can see here right like
here we got um a large transaction that
was negative uh Dex order flow and it
brought net aggregate decks down um
because they were Deltas being sold
essentially um and then over the course
of the next period it looks like they
were buying buying buying and then um
but we've seen that it's also pretty
typical that
um
um that like when spy gets to an
absolutely the most extreme point of the
day that's kind of when it gets faded um
but um again sorry topic for another
video um so so in order to go into these
other lines right the red and the green
um the red is put decks uh and the green
is called deck um and so you might think
to yourself well you know if the teal
line is negative why is the put line
positive um and the reason for that is
because uh spy participants in general
have been selling volatility today so
they've been selling puts which is why
um they've actually been getting
positive Delta by way of puts um so
essentially they have been selling puts
um meaning that they're uh
essentially uh buying shares by means of
selling puts or at least placing right
like limit orders to buy underneath the
market um but um and the reason that uh
aggregate Dex is negative is because
they've also been selling calls and
they've been selling way more calls than
they've been buying puts so just to go
over that again right if I were to buy a
put then I'm getting negative Deltas
because I'm short the market um so bot
puts would show up here uh as negative
on aggregate decks because it's like
you're selling but bot puts will show up
as positive because it's like you're
buying um sorry let me correct that last
statement I mean that sold puts will
show up as positive because you're
buying um for calls we have a case in
which a bought call will show up as
positive because it means that you're
getting long deltas and a sold call will
show up as negative because um it means
that you're getting short
Deltas um so
in this particular case we can see that
although put selling has remained
relatively constant over the course of
the day um call selling has been
increasing aggressively um and when we
look at something like this it can tell
us that okay spy Traders have a short
bias today but it's not it's not a heavy
short bias because they're selling both
sides they're selling puts below and
they're selling calls above um and why
is that oh because we're in a range and
we've been doing that all day um and at
the beginning of the day it wasn't clear
so you can see that here um we kind of
Consolidated a little bit at the
beginning then we had this big move up
and then spy Traders responded ever so
slightly um by bringing aggregate decks
um making it positive they were thinking
oh we may break out today we may be keep
running um last few days have been up on
the S&P makes sense um but then you know
it got quickly faded and as soon as that
happened and usually it's around 10:00
a.m. where we get this sort of decision
point and all of a sudden they decided
okay actually we're just going to short
volatility all day and you're like okay
that makes sense and that's what they've
been doing ever since um so this is kind
of actually telling you okay I probably
want to be fading both sides of this
range um because you know I have the red
line above and the green line
below
um now if we had a case in which uh spy
players were aggressively buying calls
so the green line would be above and
shorting puts so the red line would be
uh above as well um then that's what you
see on like Trend days where where
everyone just goes absolutely crazy and
sometimes I'll post things like that on
Twitter yeah I think that actually
mostly does it for this video it's funny
I didn't plan to spend the whole time on
spy but I think that was useful and it's
also useful just to get a sense for
what's been going on um it'll be
interesting to see here if we're
actually able to break through this
range or not we will leave like reading
SPX aggregate decks those things for
another video this is mostly just um so
that we can have a solid idea of what
all these things mean I'll recap it one
more time just in case um which is that
if I hover over here and I see that uh
aggregate putex is at uh 84 let's say 85
um then that's telling me that um people
have bought $85 million worth of shares
using options um by selling puts right
um and then this is just telling us what
our net looks like and then this is
telling us what they've done using calls
looks like they've been very short calls
I hope that this was helpful and um yeah
I'll see you guys in another video uh
Happy trading thanks for using gex